francis for people that don't know your
story you got from where you came from
to america like if you can take a minute
and just give your background on how you
came to america because as an immigrant
myself you know america is like i
remember the first time i landed and i
went to the airport i'm like i can't
believe i'm in america what was your
journey from where you came from to come
in america
well um
from where i came from to america um
it's little
complicated so this is like a two-step
story like when i come to america even
the first time that story was different
from where
i left my country the first time
because i came in america the first time
i had a job
they picked me at the airport with a
limo brought me in the four-star hotel
four-star hotel
you know check me out and
have people around me
and uh i think that day i called my mom
i'm like hey your son has made it
yeah because growing up
yeah growing up my dream was always to
go to america yeah but how i don't know
so i didn't see myself like coming in
america
in the red carpet as i did the first
time so my first day in america
not only i was in the fly
um
there was somebody at the airport
waiting for me
taking my suitcases you know
bring it in the car
dr drove me to the
hotel
then they checked me in i wasn't
speaking any english but they were so
like oh mr gano this mistaken that
i'm like damn finally in america what
city did you land in orlando orlando of
all places orlando yeah that was mickey
mouse showed up who showed up to greet
you
like in orlando it's it's walt disney
world that's what it's known for over
there
i mean what kind of
pageantry was going on when you got
there no really but i think like at that
moment
he was all america everything that i was
seeing around
uh was so impressive and just the idea
that i'm in america that america that
i've been thinking about you know like
growing up uh
i've been naming myself like uh american
boy or the staff and they've been naming
me
with a lot of nickname you know um
because i loved america and i always
been america but that's the way that i
came in america
was a red carpet but
it's a different story compared to where
i went in france in europe you know
that's is a different story that's when
i migrate there and that wasn't fun at
all
you know
because i left my country first of all
without knowing where i was going and i
couldn't even tell my family
because uh when you tell somebody that
you're living the first question is like
to where
where i don't have no destination so
you once again you're crazy you're out
of your mind oh you're going somewhere
that you don't know
where you're going
you know
and that's how i left and
it took me
over a year
then
i mean i went i get i and ended up in
morocco and trying to go to cross and go
to spain
and um
it was a long process a tough process
you know and i was there for one year
before i made it so we were attempting
uh attempting like uh in the ocean with
the um
inflatable boat
like those mobile that they use in the
swimming pool um copper time
i think i failed sixth time
i fell
and then i've been in that thing so much
that i
ended up became a captain even though i
don't know how to swim but i know how to
like put the boat in the water to how to
check the weather how to manage the wave
and everything and put the boat in the
water put my um
my friend inside and start a paddle so
that was good enough to be a captain you
know
we're trying to uh defenses uh to go
because there's two lands in a
morocco
which belong to spain
in the west is
celta and in the east is melea
north and northeast it's malaya so
and those are just protected by fences
multiple fences and by wire security on
the side security and on other sides
high security but we always like trying
to
find a blind spot to like attempt
and sometimes we succeed sometimes we
fail
most of the time we fail because the
security is so high with infrared
everything that they have to protect the
the border
because the barbed wire is on
about
i would say uh 10 miles
you know and that's all the
uh the border
so
try and that couple time fell
in barbed wires and all the stuff
but um
always loved water even though i didn't
know to swim and had a feeling that
that's where i get admitted it's crazy
yeah even till today
swimming
uh i have trying to take some courses
you know i have a poo in my
in my house i'd love to meet your
teacher
i'd love to see who teaches you how to
swim like to hold you that picture of
holding here no no no no no no no
no
if you enjoyed the short clip click over
here to watch another short clip and if
you want to watch the entire episode the
entire podcast click here
[Music]